cet autocar sous bonne escorte arrive de
mario paul à l'intérieur des dizaines de
combattants ukrainien ils font partie
des unités qui ont défendu la syrie asos
talent à marioupol la fin d'une bataille
entamée le 24 février et une victoire
pour l'armée russe qui contrôlent
presque entièrement la ville le
ministère russe de la défense qui
diffusent des images affirme que les
défenseurs d'ukrainiens se sont rendus
et sont traités dans le respect du droit
international
a commencé la reddition des militants de
l'unité nationaliste azoff et des
soldats ukrainiens bloqués l usine à
aups talent à marioupol au cours des
dernières 24 heures 265 combattants
déposer les armes et se sont rendus dont
51 ans grièvement blessé tous ceux qui
avaient besoin de soins médicaux ont été
envoyés dans un hôpital de la ville de
nioro azoff sq en république populaire
de gagner
pour les autorités ukrainiennes la
reddition est un coup dur mais on ne
parle pas de défaite ça veut dire que la
résistance de nos défenseurs ammar
hughton empêcher l'ennemi de redéployer
ses troupes presque vingt mille hommes
l'ennemi n'a pas pu opérer dans d'autres
régions et il n'a pas pu s'emparer
rapidement j'ai zappé orridge ya des
nuits n'a pas pu créer les conditions
d'enfermement de nos forces asa parisien
du côté des familles de soldats et de
paramilitaires on s'inquiète le kremlin
considère en particulier le régiment
azoff comme un groupe néonazi
qu'est ce qu'il va arriver assez haut on
savait comment la russie traite les gens
d'azov ils s'en fichent de savoir s'il
sent du régiment azoff de la police ou
de l'armée en fait
kiev espère désormais échanger les
combattants d'un hôpital contre des
prisonniers de guerre russe